got a special handshake with jay-z who
get special handshakes and jay-z what's
up I'm Kenan Thompson how y'all doing
bleacher report and today I'm gonna tell
you guys exactly when the Bron James
just talked about under neutral jersey
let's go
here's what I feel like LeBron is saying
look John what we gonna do is we gonna
run up and down the court we're gonna be
dunking on all of y'all and I just don't
want you to have hurt feelings because
we have greater than y'all also I'm
wondering if you want to maybe you know
get in contact with my barber because I
feel like you can get a better line up
you know what else can we talk about you
sure you wanna stay on the Wizards I'm
saying that you don't want to transfer
you like the best player out here but
you need some help you can just do
everything by yourself I would love to
show you our entire offensive strategy
that's why I'm covering my Jersey but
basically we're just gonna run a gun and
dunk on everybody that's the whole plan
so just get ready for that I don't even
need to watch the clip look here I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna tell you right
now you get you need to like wrangling
your pops your pops is out there making
it look like is that the other and
Nicole try to control me and take the
fun tonight for me every time I come to
LA so you just let him know to stop
calling my phone and I respect you as a
basketball player and everything but at
the same time I ain't never go where the
shoes I got my own shoes where I'll take
a t-shirt I mean I do like the triple B
but at the same time you know I'm King
James don't need to buy it that's for
sure I thought I was gonna give it to me
he's actually to buy like 15 service
time but to do that they doing
handshakes without even looking they
just know look I gotta be honest I feel
like LeBron is telling Kyrie this exact
thing why are we not together in
Cleveland like this is crazy
like the two of us out here back on the
road or trying to get back to the
championship we could have definitely
repeated but for some reason somebody
got in a pit
was it you yeah it was totally me the
Brian I got enough feeling a little bit
I felt like you should have respected
ebook yeah I feel you dawg you know I'm
saying I am the king no you know I'm
saying there you wouldn't be nowhere
even close to the chip everyone for me I
mean that's true Big Dawg but that same
time you couldn't give me a little love
so that's why I went on my mission to
try to find that love out there in the
world but it is hard I know
I know it's hard so if you want to jump
back on the train feel free at any time
so I feel like Kyrie will be going some
makers very soon looki be tapping people
without even looking at it like I feel
you everybody wants to touch me I got it
so here's the word that I think is
happening in this clip Norris was like
jay-z I got after the game trust me
doubt I'm gonna go over there give him
my special handshake he loves me you
know I'm saying because I'm taller than
him it's not a lot of people taller than
jay-z usually especially everybody when
Rockefeller was math short alright
there's my man Norris I'm talk to you in
a minute we after you talkin or hey
what's up what's going on y'all done
okay cool
hey J I got this Apple and I've been
working on I want you to hear it you
know it's a hot 16 I can do it for you
real quick
you know I'm going downtown and this is
how I get down everybody that's a clown
goes downtown you like that oh you don't
like that all right well you know I'll
go back to the studio and get back in
the lab and try to figure out something
else I'm just trying to impress you dawg
I would love one of those Rockefeller
chains but at the same time will they
fit on my neck
I got this one man my knees hurt mine
too
[Laughter]
this was Kenan Thompson here at the
bleacher report and that's what LeBron
was actually saying I love you too Brian
man